it is time for drew's news where the
soup du jour as always good news chowder
and with me at the desk world's best
co-pilot ross matthews oh hi everybody
hi
all right well uh this story intrigued
me to no end iconic bombshell pamela
anderson is ready to tell her own story
on her own terms variety reports that a
documentary all about her personal and
professional life is coming to none
other than netflix
yep that's the place to do it pamela
said on social media that she's not a
victim but a survivor and alive to tell
the real story and both her sons
reposted this note highlighting the
words real story so obviously they're
behind their mom
i'm now curious with this real story
what the
maybe the family feels the film pam and
tommy the one on hulu right now yeah yes
i
love it and i do think and i would have
to say i would not love it if it was
taking her down i already was a pam
anderson fan but my empathic
support for this woman has grown
exponentially while watching lily james
portray her in such a beautiful way so
i'll be interested to see what pam's
take because she's criticized the show
she wants to set the record straight on
her own terms
i'm just glad to see the show is not
doing her a disservice but actually
really opening up my eyes to the
sexist incredible victim wave
that she was set up for
well it's interesting you know i like
the the pam and tommy series as well i
like it a lot but if they were making a
series about your life well for sorry if
it was my life it'd be way more boring
than their life but you know no matter
how they tell your story you still want
to get it out your way your versions i
agree i hear that she's in the zeitgeist
right now she's been very very private
for years and years right
and now she's everywhere and how smart
for her to come out and say this is what
really happened good for you good for
you i can't just love that the pam and
tommy show is setting her up to tell her
own story and
in that way of just because you are are
in playboy i was in playboy okay
great fine
you do that at a certain point in your
life you're you know an exhibitionist
and you're into freedom and that's what
you're doing that does not allow
anything more to come into the
boundaries and i just i love the
discussion that this story is posing
about what's okay to do to somebody
because of their own actions and what's
not and
i i just i'm excited to hear what she
has to say me too and most importantly
you've convinced me to do playboy so
thank you so much i'm in
i'm in
rock i'll finally call them back all
right i think you would be in great girl
whatever who cares um either way you
know you're buying it you know you want
to see it by the way you are such a
playground you think so
literally i want to be centerful that's
my one demand oh my gosh that one fold
me out
moving on all right all right hey next
up snl's pete davidson is always full of
surprises and guess what he's shocking
us again people reports he may be headed
into space who saw that one coming right
he's in talks to ride in jeff bezos's
rocket the blue origin so remember
william shatner went up in space with
bezos yeah michael strahan went up there
yeah yeah well think about this p what's
been going on in 2022 for him he just
bought a ferry boat he's dating kim
kardashian
so like he's done just about everything
you can do here on earth so maybe he
should go
go out so you wouldn't say to him sky's
the limit i would not say to him sky's
the limit but you know if you're you
have like a bingo card of what pete
davidson is going to do next going to
space wasn't on mine but i mean like
what is what any predictions of what
he'll do
grow a mustache get a pet unicorn who
knows i mean he could do anything oh
he'd look good and
he uh he would look good in a in a
mustache he would yeah he would actually
i i think he's just so charming
you know it's like
he's funny he's handsome um i know
people who work with him and they just
say what a lovely human being he is
respectful of his mom oh i love him uh
lover of women like a romantic yeah he's
a lover of women all right
there's a reason they're all flocking
and i think he's got you know the goods
and the real deal
i think i know what you mean
[Music]
you